Salut bande de petits veinards que vous êtes, aujourd'hui
je vous explique une astuce de
mentalisme pour bluffer les gens mais qui est inratable. Et ça on aime
oui on aime
je trouve ça super important de vous faire la démonstration avant que vous
puissiez voir l'impact et la puissance que ça a quand vous essayez de
bluffer quelqu'un avec. Alors oui, on est plus sur de la magie que du mentalisme.
Comme tout ce qui est inratable d'ailleurs parce que mentalisme c'est jamais sûr à 100%
mais je pense que vous allez bien vous marrez avec ça. Démonstration.
- On est donc avec Céline H - C'est moi
- De la chaîne... - Céline H, wouw ! [rire]
- On a refait une vidéo heu...
dans le milieu de l'année ensemble. On en a refait une y a pas.... enfin
on a fait une vidéo, on n'a pas fait une vidéo... de [rire]
- j'ai fait l'a...
l'assistante. Un peu potiche. J'ai beaucoup aimé...
- Tu sais que dans les commentaires y en a qui ont dit, mais heu...
c'est pas possible, la prochaine fois faut que tu prennes quelqu'un qui fasse pas la gueule
- ouais...
- comme je t'avais demandé de pas parler - c'est pour ça que je continue de sourire
- là, là je souris. Je, je... Je ne, je ne vais pas cesser de sourire comme ça !
- Je vais te faire un tour, ça c'est le premier truc - Yes ! - Ensuite je vais
t'expliquer le tour, je vais t'apprendre à le faire
- je vais pouvoir le faire ? - Ouai, mais... - Ca c'est chouette !
- le but, c'est que vous aussi, vous puissiez apprendre à le faire
et en même temps heu, peut-être que tu vas avoir
des problèmes à faire des choses et dans ces cas là heu...
c'est des problèmes qu'ils pourraient peut-être avoir eux - Oui
- Sachant que tu as une capacité à avoir des problèmes
- Que tous ceux qui, comme moi, ont une petite tendance aux problèmes psychomoteurs,
rotation dans l'espace, restez. Car si moi j'y arrive,
ça veut dire que vous y arriverez parce que vraiment je suis au...
- ah le... - le top de ta life
- Je tutoies les étoiles en termes de...
problèmes dans l'espace
- Un jour on a pris un Uber ensemble
tout le trajet elle n'arrivait pas à enclencher la ceinture
mais c'était très très drôle à voir j'ai regretté de pas avoir la caméra ce jour là
- ah j'ai beaucoup ri, oui - et en fait je l'avais et voici... [rire]
- j'ai avec moi ces deux petits cartons sur lesquels sont dessinés un cerveau
C'est un test en fait, c'est un test d' analyse psychomoteur. [rire]
- Non mais tu vas voir, c'est très intéressant.
Y en a, y en a 2, celui-ci je vais le mettre ici, il va rester à vue tout le long
Vous pouvez le surveiller tout le long
et derrière celui ci, il y a des dessins, des symboles. Je te les faits pas voir à toi
Regarde pas l'écran de retour
je vous les fais voir juste à vous pour le moment. Ce sont des formes complètement bizarres
aléatoires un peu mystiques - Oui
- Qui vont déterminer si le hasard psychomoteur existe ou pas.
- Je t'ai perdue là - Ah bah... [rire] - A hasard et psychomoteur, en associant les deux
- Trop de mots étranges là - J'ai vu ça, j'ai vu hein
- En clair derrière il y a 16 cases avec 16 symboles - Oui - Et je vais...
heu, t'en faire choisir un de manière aléatoire
tu va compter tu sais, comme sur un damier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 - Ca, ça va, je maîtrise
et tu compteras en partant de la gauche vers la droite
comme comme quand on lit un livre. Ca va c'est bon ? - Ca marche... Là tu dors
- Pour ça je vais te demander de fermer les yeux
tu laisses passer les chiffres de 1 à 16 dans ta tête et spontanément tu m'en
dis un, entre 1 et 16. 1 et 16 étant inclus. Je t'écoute
- 8 - tu as choisi le 8
donc je vais juste retourner le carton et tu vas compter 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
- Tu peux ouvrir les yeux, hein - Ah - Parce que les yeux fermés tu y arriveras pas
Donc juste je retourne, et tu comptes 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
- donc sans heu voilà. Donc je compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 et 8
- Ok tu vois ce symbole là il est unique - Je le regarde, je le mémorise
- Ok, je vous le fait voir aussi. C'est le symbole qui est juste là...
voilà ici là, vous le voyez bien...
- Ok tu aurais pu choisir un des autres, suivant le chiffre que t'aurais choisi - Tout à fait
- et ce petit carton qui n'a pas bougé depuis le départ, n'est-ce pas ? Qui est juste là
a un symbole lui aussi tout particulier tu le vois dans l'écran de retour - Mais nooooon [rire]
- C'est exactement le même. Et tu peux voir qu'ils sont vraiment tous différents
-Mais nooooon
- Et on a fait exactement ce que je t'avais annoncé au départ - Donne à moi
- Je suis là pour garantir que c'est bien le même
- Ah oui c'est ça le mien, le 8 - Oui
- Mais enfin.... ! Mais quel est ce sort... Incroyable [rire]
- T'aimes bien ou pas ? - C'est très très
- choquant... - mais dans ce cas là je vais peut- être pas l'expliquer alors...
je vais peut-être le garder pour moi - Ouai, viens on fait ça ! - Viens on fait ça ... [rire]
- Là t'as tout le monde qui part, qui se désabonne
Alors pour faire ce tour il faudrait donc ces deux petits cartons - Oui
- Qui sont imprimés des deux côtés, recto verso, ça pour être imprimée sur une feuille...
Et sachez déjà que dans la description vous avez
un pdf avec les fichiers pour l'imprimer vous même.
Mais vous pouvez aussi avoir les versions cartonnées et ça je vous dirai comment...
à la fin ! - Oh c'est sympas. - Ce qui nous importe c'est celui-ci et comment il est construit
donc y a 16 symboles différents, originaux dessus. Tracés de mes petits doigts musclés sur photoshop
Je dessine comme un enfant de 5 ans on est d'accord. Il y a un moment où je t'ai menti
et où je vous ai menti c'est que... y a pas 16 symboles différents
donc en fait celui ci... et celui-ci... et celui-ci... et celui-ci, c'est le même...
mais il subit des rotations de 90 degrés - Mais nooooon... mais ouiii
- et comme c'est que des formes très arrondies et très spéciales - Mais c'est ça ! - On s'en rend pas compte
- C'est celui-ci, c'est celui-ci, c'est celui ci aussi et y en a un en bas c'est celui là
- Ah c'est énorme ! - Ils sont placés à des endroits vraiment stratégiques
pour qu'en tournant de 90° le carton
tu vois, y a pas de haut, y a pas de bas dessus hein. Y a pas de gauche, y a pas de droite
Suivant comment tu le tournes, tu vas réussir à couvrir les 16 possibilités
C'est à dire qu'au départ on était comme ça... - Ouai, le 8
- Le 8 est là mais si tu m'avais dit 2 par exemple
j'aurais mis le carton comme ça. Et là tu comptes 1 2 et tu tombes encore une fois sur le bon symbole
sauf qu'il est tourné de 90 degrés.
J'ai mis des petits indices au dos. C'est pour ça qu'il faut l'imprimer recto verso. En haut,
y a marqué numéro 1 6 8 c 14 comme un numéro de série
ça veut dire que si la personne dit 1 6 8 comme t'as fait ou 14
alors j'ai juste à retourner le carton comme ça - D'accord - Tu comprends le principe ? - Ca je l'....
- Hein, donc si je dis 6, il faut retourner comment ?
- Ha ! Il faut retourner comme ça - Exactement ! Et de manière naturelle !
- Oui, parce que là, ça se voit ! [rire]
- Ou alors, j'peux,... j'peux prétendre que... Oh dites donc ! - J'ai très très mal au poignet
- J'ai trop cuisiné ce week-end ! - En fait, comme la page d'un livre - Oui exact
- Attention ! Dis... dis un chiffre ! - 6 ?
- 6 ? - Ouai
- Si la personne dit 1 6 8 ou 14 vous retournez comme ça.
- ensuite bah il y a, y a la même astuce de tous les côtés. Tu me dis quand...[rire]
Toi aussi tu me dis quand, quand je vais trop vite hein. Pour ceux qui sont en bas,
au lieu de retourner comme ça, on va retourner comme ça.
- Logique - De bas vers le haut - Ca j'ai compris. - Si la personne dit 3
10 11 ou 16, vous retournez comme ça.
les deux autres, ceux des deux petits côtés, il y a une astuce
pour qu'on ait l'air naturel quand on les retourne. - Un peu comme toi là - Un peu comme moi là
- Parce que ça fait trois fois qu'on fait la, la séquence parce que je, je bouffe mes mots.
- Heu, c'est de le prendre en diagonale. Donc par des coins opposés
et de le tourner comme ça avec l'index - Oula, ça c'est plus compliqué - Là c'est plus compliqué, là on va rigoler
- On se souvient que j'ai du mal à attacher une ceinture dans une voiture.
- Je, je, je... j'essaye. Dis moi un chiffre ! - 4 - Oh ! - Dis donc
- Voilà exactement pas comme ça
- On r'commence
- 'commenche
- t'es pas du ch'nord ti ! On y retourne ! Pouce !
- Ok
- Majeur - Ok
- Index rotatif
- Exactement
- Tu le tires vers toi, ton index maintenant
- Mais...tu viens de l'enlever [rire]
- Tu sais que t'as fait n'importe quoi... [rire] - Tu le sais au moins ?
- Non mais c'est juste au moins, au moins pour savoir...
- Je ne comprends pas... Je crois que j'ai saisi - C'est vrai ? - Oui [rire]
- Je sais qu'il y a eu un doute. Index, index rotatif. Apparemment j'ai des trop petits doigts.
- Et attention... - Exactement, et tu le reposes à plat. - A plat ? - Ouai
- 4 5 7 ou 15. Alors vous retournez comme ça en diagonale.
- Et donc de la même manière si c'est l'un des chiffres qui est sur ce bord droit
- On va faire la même chose mais avec l'autre main
- Allez les p'tits manchots, la team manchots, on se prépare, on fait comme moi et on y arrivera !
- Donc...pouce - Ouai
- Majeur - Pas mal
- Index - Exact
- Rotatif
- Ouai, vas-y, vas-y, vas-y, tire le et pose le.
- Si la personne dit 2 10 12 13 vous retournez également en diagonale mais avec la main
gauche, l'autre main, et que vous soyez droitier ou gaucher cela n'a aucune espèce d'importance puisque les gestes se réalisent
naturellement des mains. - Juste ça demande un tout p'tit peu
d'entraînement chez soi hein - Ah oui, faut s'entrainer, c'est clair il faut s'entraîner - Soyons réalistes
- Oui. Est-ce que tu le feras à des gens ? - A moi-même déjà ! - A toi... non, mais tu vas t'entraîner ! [rire]
- Il faut s'entraîner c'est la base du truc - A moi-même - Ouai - Et je vais m'auto-épater !
- Et après, t'essayeras de le faire à quelqu'un. C'est, c'est c'est ta mission, ton challenge - A toi ! [rire] - A moi [rire]
- J'vais le faire à, à, à une amie... - D'accord
- Qui, qui va me, me.. je suis sûre, qu'elle va penser réellement que j'ai réellement des pouvoirs - Bin c'est drôle ça
- Et tu le mettras sur quoi ? Insta ou snap ? - Je vais faire ça sur Insta ! - Ok
- J'irai voir - Sinon j'embarque ça cet été sur les plages. Tu sais je fais ça aux gens, pour gagner des sous
- Mais bien sûr et moi je prends 10 % - Il lâche rien ! - J'en ai fais 30 exemplaires de, de la paire. - Encre bleue
- Merveilleuse - Tu veux pas heu...
postuler pour
- présenter les trucs dans les émissions de télé - Mais si parce que... - Ca marche super bien
- J'ai remarqué que souvent c'est ce que tu me proposais dans tes
vidéos et j'ai trouvé que je m'en sortais très bien
- Y que dans celle de juillet... - Non mais je rêvais de faire heu...
c'était quoi, c'est la roue de la fortune ? - Ouai - Ouai
- N'hésitez pas à acquérir ce merveilleux lot de jeux fascinants, énigmatiques et bluffants. La qualité est indéniable
- L'encre est particulièrement agréable à l’œil. Un jeu pour toute la famille [rire niais]
- On va les offrir comment ? On fait un concours ? - On fait un concours
- On fait un concours. Je propose... - You propose...
- C'est toi qui les fait gagner. Tu les fais tous gagner sur la chaîne - Moi j'fais gagner... Haha
- Toi tu les fais gagner. Elle sort quand la vidéo qu'on a fait ensemble ?
- Aujourd'hui, le même jour ?
Elles sort aujourd'hui - Elle sort aujourd'hui, alors. On a fait une vidéo avec Céline sur sa chaîne qui est drôle
enfin, elle ça l'a fait beaucoup rire, moi beaucoup moins...
- Hein, bah  y a vengeance à un moment donné... ! - Ah bah oui y a vengeance
- Dans les commentaires de sa vidéo sur sa chaîne, je vous mets le lien dans la description,
vous mettez un hashtag. Le tag quoi . on met quoi ?
- hashtag "Téléachat" [rire]
- hashtag "Téléachat", très bien, très efficace
- Vous mettez le hashtag "téléachat" dans les commentaires de la vidéo
que j'ai faite avec Céline sur la chaîne de Céline h
on va dire d'ici une semaine tu fais le tirage au sort ? - C'est moi qui fait le tirage au sort ? - Ouai
c'est moi qui tire au sort hashtag "Téléachat"
- Et tu m'envoies les adresses et moi je vous le poste.
Et quoi qu'il arrive, que vous participiez ou pas vous pouvez aussi dans la
description télécharger de toute manière tout pour le faire vous même
heu, avec un petit mémo qui ré explique le tour, peut-être un peu mieux que ce qu'on a fait là
enfin d'une manière un peu plus clair - J'ai tout donner moi ! - Mais c'était parfait [rire]
- J'ai vraiment essayé faire au mieux pour vous - Moi à un moment donné, je suis allé aux toilettes pour m'abonner à ta chaîne
- C'est pas vrai ! - Si, sisi, tu m'avais convaincu - C'est pour ça que t'es resté si longtemps ?
- Ouai ! - ah ouai, tu t'étouffais du coup ? - Je m'étouffais ? Ah oui, ça c'est clair j'me suis étouffé
- C'est un éventail manuel... sinon tu peux le mettre devant toi, et c'est toi qui bouge la tête
Céline ça fait longtemps que vous la voyez sur la chaîne. J'aime beaucoup ce qu'elle fait, c'est une excellente humoriste et je trouve ça
génial qu'elle se soit lancée sur youtube. J'aimerais la soutenir parce
que je sais qu'elle veut faire des tournages "Space" etc
J'en appelle à vous pour aller checker sa chaîne, vous abonnez, qu'elle puisse encore nous produire d'encore plus grosses vidéos.
Faites ça, soutenez-la vous aussi,
C'est la première fois que vous demande ça comme ça,
j'espère que vous le ferez. Un petit raid des familles quoi. Avec un peu de chance, elle n'a pas désactivé les notifications
par mail de youtube à chaque nouvel abonné.
Si on peut lui faire fumer son téléphone...
je serai fier de vous et fier de nous. N'oubliez pas de déposer un magnifique et flamboyant pouce en l'air sur cette vidéo
et puis et puis à très bientôt
bah oui, voilà, pensez à vous abonner aussi tout ça, ciao. Et là c'est pas du mentalisme c'est de la technologie parce que si tu
cliques sur le petit rond là que tu vois même si t'es depuis un téléphone, une tablette,
eh bien ça t'abonne à ma chaîne. Tu peux t'abonner, comme ça, à ma chaîne. Et ça, ça, ça fait plaisir
- Ou à la mienne - Ou à la tienne - Et oui - Donc il faut
cliquer aussi sur ta tête à toi. - Oui, cliquez sur ma tête, j'adore ça !